[Music]
good morning ladies and gentlemen or a
good afternoon depending on whether you
are in the us or in europe
i would like to welcome you to the
latest webinar in the series scientists
empowering scientists
the episode today is patch camp
equipment for the 21st century
my name is jan dolce i'm the product
manager for patchcam systems at sutter
instrument and the webinar today is
hosted by lab routes
the agenda
i will show very few introductory slides
then a telegraph will talk about
configuring a patch clan break
with solder instrument components
and then our guest speaker jonathan
ashmore from the university college
london
will tell us something about hearing or
rather tell us about recording from
cochlear hair cells can tell us about
hearing
and then the third speaker is going to
be myself and i will talk about dynamic
clamp with the d patch patch clamp
amplifier system
a number of
experiments customized bespoke
experiments at the edge of leading edge
of technology and then in the end we
will have a q and a session a discussion
the whole thing will take about one hour
for your questions on the left of your
screen you have the questions box
there's a button please indicate which
speaker your question is directed to
sometimes that's obvious
but we don't want to have to guess on
that
all questions will either be addressed
during the q a session at the end of the
webinar or we will address them offline
by email
also use them for questions for
technical issues if you have trouble
hearing or something like that
there are documentation materials they
were available as downloads
pdfs from the registration page but most
importantly a
video recording of this webinar will be
available on
labruts.com but then also on this other
instrument youtube channel soon
thereafter
and also for our customers in asia in
china in particular sorry um
it will also be on a yoku channel and
everybody who has registered for that
webinar will be notified by email about
that
let me introduce today's speakers
start with our guest speaker jonathan
ashmore
um
he got his phd in theoretical physics at
the imperial college london
and then transitioned to what he calls a
somewhat painful transition to wet lab
doing his master's
in physiology and then followed that up
with the postdoc
at ucl
um
came to university of california san
francisco where he also
met and interacted with some of the
founders of sutter instrument
then went back to the uk to the
university of sussex and then bristol
as a professor eventually and since 1996
is at the university college london
where he is today bernice katz professor
of biophysics
a fellow of the royal society and the
director of the london interdisciplinary
doctoral program
and our first speaker will be telly
who graduated in 1987 in computer
science
and
in the same year
joined instrotech the instrutech
corporation where he
went through several roles from
support
eventually to be the general manager
until in 2007 instru tech was acquired
by haka instruments where he continued
working as a general manager in that
role that's when he and i met and since
2015 i have the honor to call telly
my colleague at sutter instrument where
he works in product development and
technical support
myself i graduated in marburg in germany
doing electrophysiology and other patch
clamp recordings on insect scenzilla
and during that time i already started
consulting for exxon instruments who
hired me in 2003
um
i stayed on through several mergers
until 2011 when i first joined sutter
instrument had a short interplay
attacker electronic
and since 2014 i'm back with sutter
instrument i'm the product manager of
patch clamp systems today
and with that let's switch to the first
speaker delegations will talk about
configuring a patrick lambrick with
sutter instrument components
thank you jan
all right hopefully everyone can hear me
so my talk today's be configuring a
patch clamp rig with sutter instrument
components
for over 45 years sutter has been
constantly designing equipment so that
electrophysiologists can push the limits
we have an extensive suite of products
that include
micro pipette fabrication
micro manipulation
imaging
microscopes
noise isolation
perfusion systems
and amplifier systems we can provide a
single source for building a patch clamp
rig from the ground up
just like the one shown here
let's review the various components that
make up this rig
electrophysiological recordings are
highly susceptible to environmental
factors that introduce noise to the
signals
predominant noise sources are mechanical
vibration and then and electromagnetic
interference
satter offers a series of vibration
isolation tables and accessories from
tmc vibration control that provide the
foundation for the rig
each table provides a steady base with
active air suspension for vertical and
horizontal isolation
the two inch stainless steel top is
available in either metric or imperial
hole pattern floats to maintain a stable
level surface for our experimental setup
our most popular configuration the
at3036
is a 30 by 36 table and includes a
roll-up faraday cage from emi noise
suppression
optional accessories include casters for
making it easier to move the table
padded arm rest and air compressor for
those labs that don't have house air
now that we have our foundation we need
to build on it by adding a microscope
and its supporting components
i would like to start off with one of
the newest specialized microscope the
nan
the nan is an extension of the vastly
configurable bob
it was designed for patch clamp and in
vivo experiments
is mounted on a 9-inch rail which
provides some height adjustability
uses olympus optics
you have a choice of bx2 bx3 or single
filter cube epi fluorescent eliminator
available with or without a trinocular
head
it includes a transmitted light system
with a white light led
and with an optional ir led available in
either a 940 or 775 nanometer wavelength
the light system is impervious to spills
and can be easily removed for in vivo
experiments
here we have a nand configure for patch
clamp recordings
it includes a bx2 epi fluorescent
illuminator with trinocular head
an mt-78 motorized stage
an mp845 manipulator
white light led transmitted light system
lambda 721 is our episource
the focus stage and manipulator are
controlled by a single ro200
let's now review the various components
first the mpc200 controllers that are
not shown
the mpc200 controls up to two
mechanicals
two controllers can be
chained together as they are for this
configuration
a single roe 200 supports up to four
mechanicals
the controller is electrically quiet as
he was optimized for low noise
electrophysiological recordings
provides ultra low drift and ultra
smooth movements
has a accelerated mode for fast
manipulator movement
and supports variety of manipulator
mechanicals motorized translated and
motorized stages
the mpc200 is also multi-link software
compatible
next we have the mp78 stage features
include
table support and solid
design 25 millimeter motorized travel in
both x and y
the mpc200 controller provides 40
nanometer resolution steps
convenient home function allows stage to
be quickly repositioned
4x6 milled pocket at the center will
accommodate a variety of aluminum stage
inserts
we also have custom aluminum inserts
available
in this setup we used an mp845
manipulator which is one of our newest
manipulators
this mallet this sorry this manipulator
is mechanically robust for high
stability
uses precision cross roller bearings
has three independent axis with 25
millimeter travel
can carry up to a kilogram
has a tilted swing out gate for easy
pipette exchange this is also one of the
reasons we used it on this setup
also available in the mp800 family
is an mp845s which is a stainless steel
version which is extremely thermally
stable
and a narrow format mp865
the mp845 is controlled by the mpc200
but i want to mention the other
controller options that are also
available and that is the mpc 145.
the mpc 145 is an roe with a built-in
controller
can support up to two mechanicals you
cannot daisy chain this controller
super stable no holding current
super quiet as it powers down when
there's no movement
sub micron resolution movements less
than 100 nanometers
has a user selectable angle of zero to
90 degrees for diagonal movement
as for selectable speeds
if you prefer ros in your setup multiple
sorry multiple res in your setup you can
mix and match the controllers to get
exactly what you need
next is a transmitted light source which
is powered by a lambda tled
the
is a standalone led light source
has stable output that will last an
excess of 50 000 hours
as a high output white light led
there are several options available
including an ir led
the led state can be controlled by an
external ttl trigger
as provided by a shutter patch software
for example
the tled plus also provides an analog
input for controlling the
intensity we also have tled
dc which is a dual channel tled plus
that combines two high power leds into a
single light path
our nan uses one of our newest products
for the epi light source and that is the
lambda 721
the 721 can combine up to seven separate
led cubes with different spectra into a
single common output path
each led cube contains the led optics
and a filter
the led cubes can be placed in any of
the seven positions without any concern
for the order
led cubes are easily exchanged without
any tools
available wavelengths from 340 to 940
and our product manager chris ballard is
always on the hunt for new leds
here's a short video of the lambda 721
in action
and it just illustrates how fast the
wavelength switching occurs
another popular option for epi
illumination is the lambda f led
the fled is a high power led driver for
fluorescent microscopy
very stable output
available wavelength similar to the 721
the fled dc combines two high power leds
typically 480 and 561 but can be ordered
in any wavelength combinations provides
ultra high speed wavelength switching
another microscope option is the bob
the bob is a compact
vastly configurable upright microscope
platform ideal for variety of
applications including slice
electrophysiology
as you can see from the illustration
there are many different components that
can make up a bob
the tall optical rail with a single
connecting point for quick and easy
height adjustments is what makes the bob
unique
for a step-by-step listing of all the
available options you can visit the bot
configuration page on our website and go
through all the different components
here is one of our most popular bob
configurations which includes
a bx2 eliminator with a tri-notch head
an empty
mt-820 bob motorized translator
two mt-865 narrow form manipulators
mounted on mt-95 stands
on the mt150 w20 chamber column
on an mt-70 stand with a narrow base
plate
and centec usb camera
white light led transmitter light system
the focus translator manipulators are
controlled by two daisy-chained mbc200
controllers with a single ro roe 200
which is not shown
also not shown is a dual epillumination
provided by the fled dc
in this configuration we used our newest
mt95 stands as you can see they are
different than our classic stands but
provide the same stable support
it's in a smaller footprint
a variety of custom lengths are
available
simple installation using a single
quarter 20 or m6 set screw which
directly mounts into the table
fully adjustable x y and z axis
the x axis uses our standard dovetail
gantry for glare for greater flexibility
the mt-75 was also used in this config
configuration to hold the chamber column
the mt-75 has adjustable vertical and
horizontal axis
up to 360 degrees of rotation
quick lock mechanism for easy
positioning
solid construction provides stable
mounting
a variety of chamber columns are
available including
petri dish in various sizes
variety of commercially available
chambers
and of course if one of those doesn't
work we could also make a custom one for
you
manipulators okay i showed a few
different manipulators which bring up
the question
how do you choose
well there's no simple answer
we have many many choices to go through
the perfect combination of controller
and mechanical would depend on many
factors including space requirements the
number of manipulators on the setup the
number of roes etc
all i could say is we have a solution
for every application
if you plan on using a microscope from
either olympus zeiss nikon or leica
all the components that i just mentioned
are available on those as well including
the necessary adapters for the light
sources
i'm not going to discuss our
micropipette pillars in detail due to
the time constraints
here just two samples of pipettes that
can be made with our pullers
the p1000 uses a filament as a heating
source
while the p2000 uses a laser
if you need to pull low noise quartz
pipettes then the p2000 would be your
choice
we have many many videos on our youtube
channel regarding micropipette
fabrication
no electrophysiology setup is complete
without a perfusion system it could be
as simple as a manually controlled
reservoir or a more complex
multi-reservoir computer control system
tata offers the popular perfusion
systems and bath chambers made by
automate scientific features include
reliable solution exchange
it's available one four or eight
reservoirs
low maintenance pinch valves
the valve link and thermal clamp
controllers are compatible with our
shutter patch software
the controllers are electrically quiet
and it's available for room temperature
operation in-line heated or with both
in-line and bath chamber heating
the final piece of the puzzle is our
amplifier system
setup has a couple of options for those
as well
the feature set of the ipa will meet the
requirements for the bulk of our
customers
the ipa is available in either a single
head stage
or dual head stage configuration
typical highlights include whole cell
voltage and current clamp experiments
fully integrated patch clamp amplifier
with data acquisition system
and includes a starter patch data
acquisition software
these are some of the
applications that the ipa is well suited
for tissue slice recordings cultured
cell experiments optogenetics name a few
for those that need additional
capabilities
the d-patch ultra-fast low noise
amplifier system is for you
like the ipa it's also available in a
single or dual head stage configuration
the big difference is that we use here a
single controller and each head stage is
its own module and in that module you
have all of the
a to d converters the d-day converters
for that particular head stage plus all
the calibration constants
i'm not going to go through all the
highlights i'm just going to
point out just a couple
most importantly the noise open circuit
noise is less than 200 phantom amps and
a 10 kilohertz bandwidth and here with
no active cooling
the d-patch is uses an fpga an arm core
processor which provides built-in
computing power this computing power
allowed us to remove a lot of the analog
circuitry with software it also provides
in-field firmware upgrades
another
important highlight is the bandwidth and
sampling each d-patch head stage is
capable of one megahertz bandwidth at
five megahertz sampling rate
so the d-patch can do everything that
the ipa can do but is very well suited
for single channel recordings
recordings from nanopores
dynamic clamp experiments
and any application requires high
bandwidth
if you already have an amplifier
available then the dendrite is your
connection to sutter patch
the dendrite is data acquisition
standalone data acquisition interfaces
that shares the same specifications
as the ipa in terms of the interface
section
setup patch software is what drives all
of our amplifier systems and the
dendrite i'm not going to go into any
all the details of the feature set
you can get a demo version available on
our website
we also have tons of walk-through videos
and tutorial videos available on our
youtube channel
okay now we have choice of amplifiers
which one do i choose
well typically here we typically ask
three questions
do you plan to do single channel
recordings
then the low noise option of the d-patch
is probably what you need
do your experiments require bandwidth
that is greater than 220 kilohertz and
higher sampling rate greater than 50
kilohertz then that would also mean the
d-patch would be a better choice
finally
your experiments include dynamic clamp
well the d-patch is the only commercial
amplifier out there that has this option
my colleague jan will talk about damage
clamp option detail in his talk
finally some accessories for
organization
the gp 17 ground point and wiring kit
provides reliable low resistance
grounded connections for stock grounding
configuration inside the faraday cage
the expansion panels provide easy access
to the auxiliary input and output
channels as well as ttl outputs and they
are available for both the ipa and the
d-patch
sutter produces both polycarbonate and
coarse electrode holders
where the quartz holder minimizes
thermal expansion and provides the
highest pipette stability
to finish everything off we have
equipment racks that are available for
mounting the various controllers
so yeah there's plenty of options
available plenty to go through what i
would recommend is you contact sutter to
discuss your application
we can assist you in configuring your
rig today and of course help you in the
future if any technical issue arise
thank you for your attention and now i'd
like to switch over to jonathan for his
presentation
right here we go
so
so thank you very much
i hope this is now going to fire up
is that visible now to everybody
yes we see that
that's good so anyway thank you very
much
jan and telly for the introduction
um i'm going to tell you a little bit
about
cochlear hair cells this is a crash
course in hearing followed by my brief
exposure to the d-patch
patch amplifier which telly has just
been telling you about
to tell you what you can actually do on
a isolated cell from the cochlea so
first of all a crash course on hearing
so when you hear something you're
listening to a range of frequencies
which it can extend from a few tens of
hertz up to 20 kilohertz if you have
really good hearing that's when you're
young
um and by comparison this is what a
piano keyboard looks like a piano the
highest note on the piano extends up to
about four kilohertz
but as you get older you begin to lose
the high frequency part of your hearing
range and so this is a spectrogram when
i say cochlear you begin to lose the
high frequency components which make one
able to make us able to distinguish one
bit of speech from the next so people
then to make mistakes as their hearing
falls off
now the reason why i'm showing you this
of course is that our favorite animal
the mouse which in which you can do
genetics has a hearing range which only
starts at about one kilohertz but the
surprising thing is of course a mice
hearing and in fact many rodents hearing
goes up way beyond beyond 60 kilohertz
possibly up to 80 kilohertz and more
and that means that this range of
hearing as such
is on a frequency range which is beyond
what most electrophysiological systems
up to now are capable of of recording
i'll come back to that in a moment
the way of course in which our mammalian
hearing works is is that the sound is
separated
by a structure called the basilar
membrane inside your inner ear and that
is then signaled off along the auditory
nerve to the brain and there's about
three thirty thousand or so audrey nerve
fibers in arsenal about ten thousand in
a mouse and the cells which actually
detect the movement of the basilar
membrane are called the inner hair cells
they have a most interesting ribbon
synapse down the bottom but at the top
they have these little processes called
hairs you can also see on with a light
microscope which is the s where the
sensory organelle of the hair cell
there's another class of cell called the
outer hair cell and they turn out to be
motor cells actuators which amplify the
sound once it enters the ear
so let's start off with a little bit of
as it were electrophysiology
this is the equivalent circuit of a cell
they sit in an epithelium so the current
enters from essentially the apical end
it goes through the ion channels the
conductance indicated like so and then
passes through the cell and passes out
through mainly potassium channels at the
base of the cell and the substantial
fraction of that current actually passes
out through the membrane
capacitance the lipid here and so the
combination of the capacitance and the
resistance of the cell produces a
low-pass filter which means that
very fast signals produced by deflection
of a hair bundle backwards and forwards
will actually get filtered out
now there's been a huge amount of
interest recently in what that actual
iron channel at the top of the hair cell
is
um this is the best guess so far it's
turned out to be very difficult to find
because it turns out to be a complex not
a simple channel and the idea is as the
bundle moves backwards and forwards a
little filament pools on this channel
and mechanically gates it open but there
are all sorts of other accessory
proteins as well as tmc1 what's the
channel itself um and it's the
identification of the way in which that
complex works has been very difficult
but the identity of tmc1 has really only
been
established more or less convincingly
over the past few years or so
but there's also huge amounts of extra
work both in electrophysiological
physiology and
cell biology from a number of labs such
as robert fetty places and tony reaches
jeff holtz baltimore cotty anthony peng
and many many others so it's a hot area
where you should watch this space things
are going to happen there
but i'm going to tell you now about
outer hair cells out of hair cells i
said are motor cells and most of the
experiments i'm going to be talking
about are actually done on an inverted
microscope
which gives you access to isolated cells
once you've protected the mic from the
cochlea mammalian outer hair cells are
sort of peculiar because not only do
they change lengths but they generate
force when the membrane potential
changes
so here is a cell an outer hair cell
from a guinea pig they can easily be
recognized because they have
these hairs stereocilia and they have
also
a new displaced nucleus and here's the
patch pipette down the bottom so when
the inside goes negative positive of the
cell the cell gets a bit shorter when it
goes negative it gets a little bit
longer by about four percent or so and
the mechanism which is responsible for
that is a protein which is embedded down
the sides of the outer hair cell
membrane just the outer hair so not the
inner hair cells and that's called a
protein which is called prestin and was
identified um by peter dalash's lab in
chicago in the year 2000 but as far as
the em is concerned it looks like a
membrane particle about eight nanometers
in diameter or so and so it's probably a
tetramer of this uh molecule preston
which can be found um from a genetic
screen
however it turns out that preston is
actually a membrane iron transporter
it's a member of the super family of
solute carrier super family number 26
and that produces problems as they're
right it's not actually an ion channel
now the way in which one of the ways in
which it was identified is because when
the cell undergoes a movement there's
actually an associated dating charge and
this dating charge can be seen if you
step the membrane potential very quickly
both for the whole cells but also for
individual little patches of membrane
down the side of the membrane and if you
follow this patch of membrane using
essentially a laser light with a
position detector you can see that the
patch actually moves in and out of the
membrane potential changes
and the charge associated with that
gating current
um can be essentially follows or even
possibly precedes the patch movement
itself
now the time constant of this is quite
short in the order of about
somewhere around between 10 and 15
microseconds so we're already into high
frequency
electronics as it were
and what we would really like to know is
what's the limiting time constant of
that gating charge movement
so that was the as it were the
electrical fingerprint which enabled
preston to be identified now the way in
which charge is to be measured most
readily in a cell
is because if you imagine a capacitance
in a cell it as you add charge or take
charge away from it essentially that's a
linear process so
by measuring the amount of charge that
you can transfer as a function of
membrane potential you can actually work
out what the membrane capacitance is it
turns out for an outer hair cell that is
not a linear line it's actually a
non-linear line
and the derivative of the charge
transfer as a function of membrane
potential is actually a capacitance and
that's been called a nonlinear
capacitance and the capacitance can be
most readily i measured in a cell using
some sort of lock-in amplifier method as
a way that was originally described by
marty and neo in 1983 when all the patch
clamp technology was first introduced
and that's where of course the d-patch
comes in and extremely useful it's got a
very nice
lock-in
amplifier facility that to show you so
now what i'm going to show you some
one very preliminary of a few
measurements that were made from a rat
outer hair cell
it's a rat not a guinea pig because you
can't get guinea pigs for love or money
post-brexit in this country
and here is an isolated outer hair cell
from a p18 rat and it's been patched on
the base
and when the membrane potential is a
step for a variety of different
potentials you can see that there's an
outward current that developed and here
is the current voltage curve that you
then measure
but the strange thing is there's a
little blip right at the beginning and
also at the end which you can't null by
cancelling out the membrane
transients and that in fact is this
gating current
so if we look at it on a slightly higher
time scale you can see here is this
deviation from the linear behavior so
here i would be plotting the current as
a function of membrane potential as i
step through the different steps for
that particular cell and you can see
it's a kind of non-linear curve with a
kind of half point somewhere around
about 10 minus 10 millivolts in this
particular cell
now the nice thing about the d patch is
that you can immediately switch to a
lock-in routine and when you do that it
implements the
linda near algorithm it gives you a very
nice
bell-shaped curve which is essentially
the derivative of this particular curve
here and you get two things for the
price of one not only do you get the the
capacitance in absolute terms so this
actually measured the capacitance of the
cell but you also get the iv curve and
hence the conductance of the cell at any
particular potential and the readout for
that set of data took about 15 seconds
so it's it's a very efficient way of
doing it these capacitance changes are
quite small but the resolution of this
particular algorithm in the d-patch is
even better than that and you can
probably measure the femto farads
necessary for
cell expression uh experiments
so that was an interesting experience
with the d-patch and it was very
impressive there's an interesting bump
here which i don't quite know what
that's to do but again that's something
which can be explored
now where should we go from here well
one of the interesting things of course
is that if you then measure the
capacitance not at 500 hertz which is
what the
the d-patch was measuring this
capacitance but a variety of different
mem different of measuring frequencies
what does the capacitance do well it
turns out that it falls off and in some
experiments that jonathan gail and i did
a long time ago it looks as though that
non-linear capacitance maximum begins to
have a kind of caller frequency
somewhere around about 10 kilohertz so
the question is is that the limiting
ability of the prestin to change
confirmation
and of course it's not completely
satisfactory because of those days a
long time ago we were using electronics
which had limited bandwidth and so it's
a very exciting prospect to see whether
we can actually do better using the wide
band of the d-patch
now just very briefly finally how does a
transporter work as a molecular motor
well it turns out the transporter has a
cytoplasmic vestibule which as the anion
moves in and out of it it undergoes a
conformational change in the plane of
the membrane and so you could imagine
that if this iron moves in and out fast
enough you could actually get changes in
the
area of the
protein and then because there's so much
protein crowded into the lateral
membrane it gives rise to cell length
changes and therefore a force generation
which will modify the mechanics of the
cochlea itself
it definitely requires intracellular
chloride um the only known blocker is
solicitate which is there's been
psychophysical data about that for ages
which is aspirin interferes with your
hearing because aspirin is the
methylated version of salicylate and the
transport itself is a pretty low
efficiency chloride transporter but
there's so much of it that it probably
is capable of regulating the chloride
inside the cell
so then how does this all fit together
so the idea is here is the essentially
the equivalent circuit of the
of the hair cell outer hair cell in a
hair cell
here is the current flowing through the
transducer and out through the
conductance of the base
and you can imagine that if the membrane
somehow is stretched or pulled that
little iron may be forced in and out of
that vestibule and it's rather like a
piezoelectric current rather like a sort
of gas lighter that you would use to
light your stove
and the idea is that
that's been gradually emerging
particularly from the work of kuniawa
more recently from rick rabbit
is that that current becomes essentially
what looks like a piezoelectric current
which can flow in the opposite direction
to the membrane capacitance current and
therefore nullified and ineffectively
reduce the effective capacitance of the
cell so the time constant will become
very very small and so what this means
in circuit terms is that instead of
there being current going into the
transducer there's another source of
current which is actually going through
the lateral membrane
so what are these biophysical problems
that require new generations of
recording systems first of all we'd
really like to know whether iron channel
kinetics actually determine the upper
limit of hearing
um and you need for that wide bandwidth
and low noise recordings
why should animals only be hearing up to
100 kilohertz is that the limiting uh
opening rate of the iron channels that
you find at the tips of the stereocilia
and also are there limits to the
mechanics of sound detection itself how
does hearing work above 20 kilohertz
what does the outer hair cell actuator
do at these very very high frequencies
is that hypothesis actually correct and
it comes back to this little problem
again which is that well what's the
mouse actually doing with its hair cells
once it you get beyond the conventional
range that electrophysiology can look at
in other words the 10 kilohertz or so
and that maybe is the kind of direction
which we should be thinking about going
for in the future
so finally just thanks to sutter
instruments um for the loan of this
d-patch to jan and adam who um were
helping the um all of us on the start um
faculty and students on the biology of
the nao workshop at the mbl
marine biology labs in woods hull in a
couple of years ago and that was a great
introduction to this particular machine
so thank you very much for your
attention
and if i can stop sharing my screen now
i will
return you now to
jam
thank you very much
that was a
very exciting talk about i'm excited to
hear
about the
results that the d-patch generated
during that
demo loan
this summer
and that you were able to make
meaningful to generate meaningful
recordings with that and that the high
bandwidth which is one of the features
of the
e-patch
that that
actually showed useful and that it opens
um the
exploration of uh field that um is
unexplored
so let me see whether i can share my own
screen now start screen sharing yes
and um
should be back to where we were before
in just one moment my screen will
hopefully start sharing
here we go
okay the final talk of the day
rather than disappearing that should
have started presenting mode okay here
we go
the title of my talk is dynamic clamp
with the d-patch
patch clamp amplifier system
i'm going to talk about
bespoke experiments customized
experiments at the edge of technology
as i said my name is jan also i'm the
product manager for the patch clamp
systems at suther instrument i'm going
to give you a brief introduction about
what dynamic clamp is it's not something
that was newly invented but the d-patch
has the ability to take it to the next
level
i'm going to talk about how dynamic lamp
is implemented in the d-patch system in
particular
and then i will show you two scenarios
in a live demo one is eliciting action
potentials by injecting current steps
into a model cell
and then the visualization of the
dynamic clamp current that in essence
helps you monitor the experiments and
making sure
that what you think you apply to the
cell is actually what you apply to the
cell and then i'll summarize and
again explain what the advantages of the
d-patch system are compared to other
systems
that provide dynamic lamp what is
dynamic lamp it's also known as
conductance clamp
and
it was first introduced in 1993 by two
separate groups uh eve martyr at
brandeis and robinson in kauai in
cambridge uk and in japan
and since then there have been quite a
number a large number of publication
publications with dynamic lamp
here is one example from
astrid prince at all um showing an
aplasia neuron action potentials from
the plesian neuron
during a spike train
the initially relatively short action
potential gets longer in the control
conditions
and then this effect can be blocked
pharmacologically by blocking two types
of potassium channels ia in the delayed
rectifier potassium channel and this
pharmacological block can then be
rescued by injecting the currents that
these two channel types
uh conduct
um
using dynamic clamp and then this
initially short and then
get getting longer uh action potential
this behavior also occurs so in this
case you can mimic currents and then and
that lets you
um explore what these currents would
have looked like to begin with either
with a formula pharmacological block or
of course the same would be if you use a
knockout mouse knockout model
another example what uh
how dynamic clamp can be used is by
doing the opposite thing by not
injecting the currents as
activated currents but by using a
negative conductance
and mimicking the pharmacological block
by subtracting negative currents and
again this
effect of the action potential getting
longer in the course of a spike train
is
locked disappears as if it was
pharmacologically blocked
third scenario that i'm not going to
talk about today would be mimicking
synaptic input to a cell in a slice in a
tissue
sample
so look at the let's look at the
verbal definition of dynamic clamp if we
do voltage clamp we inject and then also
measure the current that's required to
maintain a given membrane voltage
in current clamping contrast
we inject a fixed amount of current
and in dynamic lamp we inject a current
that is a function of the measured
voltage not a fixed amount unlike
regular current clamp
so the injected current in essence is
a conductance
that is a function of the voltage the
membrane potential here and we have to
take the reversal potential into account
and if we set that to zero then in
essence that would be a leak conductance
a leak
channel
but in reality it's a little more
complicated we have the sum of all
conductances as a function of voltage um
the membrane voltage minus their
respective
reversal potentials
and this is the same
equation and if we look at the
one of the conductances that we
typically have in a cell sodium
conductance
that would be governed by
an activation gate in the case of the
voltage-gated sodium channel that has
three particles and an inactivation gate
h that is only one particle
that leads to a series of
differential equations here i'm not
going to go into the math
um all i want to highlight here is the
dm by dt looking at the
activation gate
it's a function of time and that time
that dt the time intervals
need to be both short and constant
that's important no wobble
and that's the challenge
doing that with conventional
electrophysiology systems is not that
easy why is that because a conventional
edge clamp system consists of an
amplifier that puts out an analog signal
that gets fed into a computer interface
and the computer interface is controlled
by software the software also puts out
um stimuli uh to the amplifier
but what's important is this connection
is typically usb and the computer
interface other the computer
typically runs on either windows or a
mac machine
and those are
operating systems that are not real-time
operating systems that means if you want
to do dynamic clamp you need those
constant real-time intervals that means
you need to split up this computer into
two computer computers one that's
responsible for data collection
and the other one that controls the
dynamic clamp and runs a real-time
operating system so that you have the
fast and consistent timing
that you need to uh compute the current
that you want to inject back as i said
[Music]
windows or mac
are not real-time operating systems so
they can't be used
and you can't using the usb connection
because because all that introduces
delays that are not only not under our
control they're also not constant
hit this stage the the d-patch
ultra-fast low noise amplifier system
and
this is um in essence something that
looks like this we have the head stage
then we have an interface
and
then we have
fpga a field programmable gate array
and also two arm core processors in the
system they give you a lot of computing
power and they take the place of the
dynamic clamp computer the second
computer that i had on the previous
slide
so if we look at that here um on on the
d-patch system we have a head stage we
have an interface that's in the blue box
the preamplifier here
uh fpga and armcore are in the main unit
and the software runs on the computer
and that's exactly what i have oh um but
before i forget
depending on the conductance model
this can run at update speeds up to 500
kilohertz and that's not the sampling
rate the sampling rate is 5 megahertz 10
times as fast
but the dynamic clamp
current can be updated
at that speed of up to 500 kilohertz
and what i have
on my desk here sitting on my desk
is
exactly that um i have my d patch main
unit
then i have the auxiliary output one
connected to the auxiliary input one and
why that's important
we'll get to that in a minute
i have the pre-amplifier unit here
and i have the head stage with a model
cell in cell setting and i don't even
need a whole lot of shielding you're
gonna see when i switch to to the
software demo uh there's not a whole lot
of noise going on there anyway
the whole thing is controlled by shutter
patch software i'm not going to go into
any uh details of the basic operation as
telly already mentioned we have a number
of videos on our youtube channel about
that
um
i'll just uh briefly talk about dynamic
models and we will
use the hodgkin-huxley style gate model
um in the demos that i'll show we also
have a goldman hodgkin cats conductance
model
in the minecraft model and then we have
what's called variable conductance model
and again
in the interest of time i'm not going to
go into that today um one thing we are
considering the variable conductance
model uh could be folded into the
hodgkin-huxley style in essence with a
constitutively open conductance you can
mimic that as well so that may change in
the
user interface um i'm also not going to
go into too much detail about the user
interface of the
dynamic clamp
that is explained in a webinar that we
held last year with greg helmstead
introduced a lot and
i also lifted a number of slides from
his presentation
where he introduced
um quite a few
aspects of the dynamic lamp and also
explained the basic and uh um basic
operation of the user interface in that
area
that's available on our youtube channel
um
we um the first scenario that i'm going
to show you is elicited action potential
and i'm going to show that in both
membrane tests and
then i'll
i will create an fi plot
in the membrane test here's the membrane
test window we have our voltage signal
our current step
um and here is the d-patch control panel
and that looks a little
complicated at first side but we really
only need to focus on two components one
is up here we are in current clamp mode
and that little flag
shows that a dynamic lamp is loaded
and the second one is here the holding
potential um i'm introducing injecting
minus 250 pico amps that is because my
model cell is a passive model so just
the passive homic and with the
capacitance model cell that doesn't have
uh
resting potential so i'm mimicking in
essence a resting potential if you do
something like this to a real cell that
cell might not be all that happy because
keep in mind if you inject a steady
current you're moving charges that means
you're changing the ionic composition in
the vicinity of the cell you're either
depleting or enriching ions potentially
so you probably don't want to do that
with a real cell
and then what i'll do is with the
hodgkin-huxley model loaded here i will
not use a
constant holding
conductance but i will use what's called
a conductance stream and i'll explain
that a little bit in the live demo
um where i can in essence change the
holding conductance um during my
experiment using the d patch control
panel
and then the second thing i'll do is
i'll create an fi frequency over current
plot where i
inject current steps of increasing
amplitude and then look at the action
potentials that elicits and i'll measure
the frequency and plot that in real time
the second scenario i'm going to show
is
synthesized
voltage-gated sodium
currents i'll first create an iv plot
then i'll show steady state in
inactivation and recovery from
inactivation and in the interest of time
i'm probably going to gallop through the
other ladder too relatively quickly
um so here looking at that that's that
would be the iv plot here would be the
uh
steady state inactivation and here would
be the recovery from inactivation from a
lengthy conditioning
pulse here
the longer the interval is to my test
pulse the more current sodium currents
recover
that let me switch to
software setup pitch runs on igor
two components that we're going to work
with the dynamic lamp editor
and the routine editor
and over here is the
the d-patch control panel
excuse me
and
first as i said i will run
the uh the membrane test and i need to
load i'm going to load my hodgkin-huxley
model here
this is in essence run continuously i
have three conductances a sodium
potassium and a leak current sodium has
the
activation and inactivation gate as i
explained before
and if i load this
the little flag here
shows it's there and then
we
have a constant train of um
action potentials here that is because
my holding current hasn't been enabled
yet so let me enable that
and then we only get action potentials
during the
duty cycle of this
100 pqm step over here is the uh the
amplitude um only during the duty cycle
and i get um
action uh action potentials here
and then i can play with the holding
conductance this is 1.2 micro siemens uh
it starts and i can use the triple
slider here that's a control that we
have in several
instances in the deep edge control panel
where i have three sliders with
different sensitivity and i can reduce
the conductance to the point
where
uh
oh
sorry what i should actually do is make
the change here the holding conductance
was uh fixed at 1.2 micro siemens i need
to use the conductance stream in over to
control that over here so let me load
let me update the the model conductance
model has been updated and now i should
be able to
reduce the holding conductance to the
point where i only get a single action
potential
at around one micro siemens and if i
reduce it further
somewhere around
830 850 i start seeing action potentials
and if i go high enough with the holding
conductance then eventually i'll get
action potentials throughout the entire
sweep of the membrane test
so that is just one example this is my
completely
passive
model cell here
that with dynamic clamp
i need to enter 1.2 micro
with my dynamic lamp fires action
potentials the second thing i was going
to show you was
running an fi plot so here are my
current steps of increasing
amplitude i'm recording the current and
the voltage signal
um here's my stimulus out and then
in real time i'm plotting the frequency
versus the segment amplitude here
and if i run this it looks like this up
here are my current steps
and down here
are
the um
the of the action potentials
and here the frequency is plotted in
real time
starting at about
uh
minus 200 pico amps i i get a relatively
high frequency
and
let me switch to the second scenario
here
i have
the the derivative of the hodgkin-huxley
conductance in essence
let me duplicate that and call that
dynamic lamp
n a v
what i want to do here
derive in essence from the the original
hodgkin-huxley model i'm only interested
in the sodium conductance i'm not
interested in the potassium
or
the the leak conductance
and
then i'm going to use a different
routine this is a derivative of the
sample routine iv the main let me
highlight the main changes here for the
input channels rather than using current
and voltage i'm using the auxiliary in
you remember i'm feeding my auxiliary
out
signal
back into auxiliary in i also need to
derive my voltage signal from auxiliary
out three
and then i also have a virtual signal
where i have the stimulus
that that that's the representative of
my stimulus signal here
then
for the output signal that is my voltage
steps here and for the measurements i'm
measuring the peak current the absolute
peak um during the the step and i'm
plotting that versus the command and
that gives us
of course
i also need to load this i still have
the hodgkin-huxley model it
and that of course does not give us a
good sodium iv curve so let me load the
sodium
iv
and
run this
and then what we're getting
is
sodium inward currents here and again
this is my model cell my my totally
passive model cell
sitting on my desk
generating what looks like
um
sodium currents that are governed by the
conductance model the hodgkin-huxley
model that i have loaded
um
this can also be used for assay
development and
let me just show real quick the uh the
other two
back to the
routine editor uh the voltage-dependent
inactivation so what we see here is
um at the
end of uh
an inactivating a conditioning step we
see the
current activating more and more but we
also see it's bottoming out here at the
beginning that is because my holding
conductance is too large
so let me
put that 0.5 micro
and run that again and now it doesn't
bottom out anymore
and we get the same
should have only autoscaled the y-axis
here
get the same thing and
very briefly
let me run the
recovery from inactivation
executing this so what we have here is
our inactivating step
and then
at the end of the step
the intervals
between the step and our test pulse
increase and here again i show in real
time the recovery
and sorry about running over a little
bit let me briefly summarize
the advantages of the d-patch system uh
we have a powerful dynamic lamp engine
with update rates as i mentioned of up
to 500 kilohertz
you do not require any third-party
hardware for that
that is a big advantage over other
systems available
we have multiple conductance models that
are supported
the synthesized current can be monitored
as i just showed you um and that can
also be used for essay development and
we have dynamic lamp pools i didn't go
into that too much um that there was in
essence the the conductances that i
selected from the data acquisition
management and analysis software is
integrated and included with the d-patch
we have the the conductance settings are
saved with the experimental data
metadata again this is something
that's in in other presentations that
we've done in the past are stored
and there's powerful analysis tools
available and with that let's switch to
the question and answer session well
switch over to telly for that
thank you jan okay we do have a couple
of few questions here um
just wanted to know from michelle how
much time do we have
we have uh about five to ten minutes
left
okay so then let me uh go through a few
of the questions so i'm gonna first take
a few questions that were
addressed to me so i'll handle those
first and then i'll ask the questions
that were for jan and jonathan
so one question came in can you link two
ipa together to create a virtual double
channel amplifier yes you can so we in
the in both setter patch we support
multiple ipa so it's not just two single
ipas but you can mix and match a double
in a single ipa or two double ipas to
get you basically double the channels
that you need
another question does setter offer an
installation service to help build the
setup at the customer site yes we do
and that is something that we discuss
with the customers when we are
configuring
the um the setup and that's an option
for them
final question for me can magnets be
used on the stage platform to guide to
secure cables well you can't attach
magnets to the stage platform itself but
on the 4x6 insert
that is available in stainless steel and
you could use magnets and and tool
holders on that four by six riser
okay so now let me go in and ask a few
questions uh
for
uh first let's start off with yan can i
program my own function for conductance
yes you can um that is something i
didn't show you would um put that in let
me switch back i think everybody still
sees my screen yet in the dynamic clamp
editor in essence what you would do you
would um create a channel
that you call
my channel and then uh for an alpha and
beta in essence for for one of those
constants what you can do is
you just call your ego function
and
that ego function could
um
execute a will will execute when uh
whenever you run this model you can also
define that as a tau and infinity and
you would make that constitutively open
in essence a first order
and the initial state um is this is on
in this case and that way you can do
that you can also combine multiple
conductances
and you can use with the conductance
stream you can even use an arbitrary
waveform
to run that
okay since you are still in present mode
let me ask then a couple of other
questions
can i use a complex waveform such as a
current recording for dynamic clamp
yes that's that's exactly what i uh what
i just uh mentioned you you would use a
conductance stream
um in this case and you can define the
conductance stream and that's why i
didn't let me do that earlier because
that was defined for the sodium current
here already
you can use let me switch to the routine
editor
in essence in your waveform
what you would use
edit the waveform rather than for
example a value in an increment you
would use a template here
and that
template could be something here like a
uh
let's look at the template duration
that that could be uh
a train i'm zooming in here sorry um
that there will be a train of
uh potentials
of action potentials that that's used as
as a template here this is from uh from
one customer
um
as for for our output but i would have
to define that for the conductance
stream sorry that was my mistake so here
this this is this is where you would do
that you would define that as
stored obviously
the template
use this
set to template duration apply this and
then here
this
um
sequence of action potentials will be
used as the conductance stream and again
you can combine up to two conductance
screen streams so you have a lot of
flexibility here
and i'm looking forward to the
experiment some of them in progress
actually where this is
being put to good use
thank you
jonathan here's a question for you have
we identified all the ion channels
present in the cochlea
well i guess up to a point but obviously
what makes
any system interesting is the vari is
the different variants of ion channels
that you actually find
so by and large in hair cells most of
the ion channels are probably
potassium channels of various sorts
so the rapid answer is yes
but it goes one step further than that i
mean we're actually interested in the
confirmation of these channels where
they are in the cochlear and also the as
essentially if you have a complex
type of ion channel interacting with
many other proteins such as you find in
the transduction step itself
then i think we're in we've identified
them but we don't know how they actually
all assemble together it's a structural
problem at this stage
thank you here one more for you what are
the bandwidths of interest for the
auditory system
yeah that's a thorny one i think
i mean i think it's it's it's really
interesting i mean this question that's
been around ever since single iron
channels were first identified which is
what's the opening rate of an ion
channel and there are theoretical ideas
as to what that might be nobody's
actually sort of measured them
they've made good estimates in the
sub-microsecond range
but as i mentioned one of the curious
features is that you don't actually find
animals listening at frequencies of one
megahertz perhaps they don't even need
it biologically but even more
importantly
is it that the transduction step itself
limits the bandwidth of of of hearing in
other words frequencies up to but not
all that much more than about 100
kilohertz or so
thank you jan here's one for you is this
system suitable for simultaneous patch
clamp and calcium transient recordings
in the single neuron of the brain and
spinal cord slide
i would
think yes if calcium transient recording
if you mean like fewer uh measurements
for ratio matrix metric measurements we
should be able to
get that in but that is really something
that we would ask you to directly get in
touch with us so we can
discuss the uh you specific requirements
so if you could shoot me an email
yuansetter.com.com
or on sutter.com on the tech support
page you have all our emails uh then we
will get back to you um or actually we
should have your and can directly get
back to you about this question and
discuss that in more detail
ah here's a few more is it possible to
measure gap junction conductances
between two different neural uh neuronal
units sorry neuronal cells
um i assume that's also for me then uh
that should be possible um with the
d-patch 2 with the dual head stage
version you should be able if you can
etch the two cells simultaneously you
should be able to measure that
that should be as simple as a resistance
recording yeah i don't see why that
would not be possible
okay one more thing
is it uh sorry is it possible to do the
fast scan voltometry experiment to
measure the release of dopamine
from neuronal cells
that is possible at this point
within a limited
voltage output range we are working on a
voltammetry head stage though
that can be used
for the d-patch
the d-patch
supports the use of different types of
head stages so it would automatically
recognize that it's a different head
stage and
uh have the scaling uh internal scaling
and everything uh adapted
um
let's get back to you once this is ready
or um
if
depending on the
output voltage
that you need uh it might be possible
today
um but for most voltammetry i think
you're you need to be more positive than
than one volt and at this point we can't
do that
can i just make a comment here i think
that this is a very attractive feature
of any software programmable head stage
that you can actually do this sort of
kind of switching
and it requires minimal changes of the
hardware because most of the hard work
is actually being done by the software
that is correct yes
you will need different uh
hardware in in this case because the
output range is limited by hardware
and also voltammetry
head stage
needs less complex
circuitry so it might even be able to
offer that at a lower price than a
regular head stage
okay here's a question that i will
tackle we are planning to buy an
amplifier to to do these experiments
mentioned above may i use clamp fit
software to analyze data i do not know
how to use igor pro
well yes we do have an export option
in sutter patch that will allow you to
go to either
abf i believe it's a 1.8 format also
atf but um you do not need to know how
to use igor to use sutter patch we've
built an entire application that uses
igor as our engine
and there may be already the tools built
into solar patch that may handle a lot
of the analysis for you
if you send me or yawn an email
with the exact analysis requirements
we could advise better
can i just can i just add that this was
my problem as well and so i did find
myself using the export function quite a
lot to to look at the data subsequently
but i think it's just a question of
getting onto the learning curve for igor
that is a very valid point um thanks for
making that jonathan um
it's a
relatively small learning curve actually
for a lot of people
it's a fairly common question can i
export
the
data to analyze it in something that i'm
more comfortable with whether that's
matlab whether that's glam fit or peak
lamp but particularly peak lamp users
find their way around souther patch
usually very quickly and in fact we have
people who
converted completely convert and
converted from peak lamp to using
starter patch throughout their lab
okay there's a few questions here but i
think we've already passed
our our limit so i think we will try to
answer those um offline by email
well i'd like to thank everybody for
attending
this webinar
yan any last minute
remarks
other than yes thank you very much to
everybody from me as well and um as
telly said all questions that have not
been addressed here in the q and a
session will get back to you by email
and
thank you very much and have a great
rest of your day or have a great evening
you